[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing potion ears
now potion making was no easy feat
it required years of studying and
dedication to the craft becoming an
expert potioneer was a rare achievement
and unlike spellcraft only a handful of
potion makers are famous enough to earn
spots within history texts at hogwarts
while some became potion makers for
money others devoted their lives to the
craft out of pure love
today we're going to take a look at both
types of potioneers and see what type of
impact they left on the wizarding world
5. hector dagworth granger
hector dagworth granger was one of the
most eclectic potioneers in britain
some have speculated that he might have
been a distant relative of hermione
granger although hermione herself was
never able to verify that fact
but besides his heritage hector dagworth
granger is such a memorable potioneer
because he actually founded a society
for fellow potion makers appropriately
named the most extraordinary society of
potioneers this high society group was
made for only the greatest wizards and
witches
together they would share their love of
brewing magical elixirs and drafts
although historical records don't reveal
too much about dagworth granger's
particular achievements we do know that
he excelled at making love potions like
many other potioneers of the time he
likely sold or licensed his concoctions
for quite a high price
4. tilden toots
tilden toots was a prolific potioneer
and a cunning businessman by the time
harry potter was enrolled in hogwarts
tilden had already made a name for
himself as a popular radio show host and
herbologist his show was called toots
shoot and roots and it tackled every
yard and garden question that came up in
the wizarding world
since it was a constant program on the
wizarding wireless network tilden might
actually have been the most famous
potioneer of his era often listeners
would send tilden their questions via
owl and using his considerable knowledge
of magical plants and potions
tilden offered up the best advice that
he could find
once when a listener's flitterblooms had
all died dildon claimed that using both
reducing potions combined with
re-germinating potions would be enough
to bring it back to life
another time tilden discussed honking
daffodils and how to conceal the sound
of the extremely loud plants from nearby
muggle neighbors
thanks to the potions he created and the
income generated from his program tilden
was one of the wealthiest potioneers of
his time
he was also married to daisy hookum a
fellow potioneer who decided to live her
life without magic for a full year in
order to document muggle life
3. fleemont potter as you might have
guessed flemont potter is a relative of
harry potter's
born sometime before 1910 flemont was
actually harry's grandfather on his
father's side
as a potter flemont was a distant
descendant of the perils and part of a
traditionally pureblood family like
every other member of his family
fleemont was sent away to hogwarts
while there flemont quickly learned the
art of jewelling thanks to the bullies
that would often tease him about his
name
during that time flemont also picked up
another skill
potion making
it's hard to know what pushed harry's
grandfather to focus on potion making
but he must have been one of his
professors favorite students
by the time fremont graduated he had
created a new potion that would
transform magical marts all around the
uk
it was called sleekeezy's hair potion it
was able to straighten even the curliest
hair
unusually flemont sent the hair potion
to china for manufacturing which wasn't
common at this time perhaps potter chose
china due to one of the potions most
important ingredients asian dragon hair
the cells of flemont's new hair bomb
were enough to almost instantly
quadruple his savings
a bundle of wealth that he passed on to
his son and later harry potter
by the time the once boy james was a
teenager
the elder potter allowed sirius black to
come live with him
sirius was a black sheep amongst his
slytherin-loving family members and was
grateful to find a temporary home with
flemont and james
only a few years later after james
graduated and married lily evans
fleemont passed
somehow he contracted dragon pox both
flemont and his wife euphemia soon died
from the disease
2. arsenius [ __ ] arsenius [ __ ] was
once a professor at hogwarts teaching
defense against the dark arts to bright
young witches and wizards but he was far
more than a professor
[ __ ] contributed to countless volumes
of magical texts and publications
on his own he was responsible for potion
course books like magical drafts and
potions potion apostle and regularly
contributed to scholarly journals like
transfiguration today
in the latter he wrote a seminal piece
that compared and contrasted the disease
of lycanthropy with what commoners knew
as werewolf free
although [ __ ] likely created many
potions of his own
we don't know which ones within his
textbooks were his specifically
when harry potter ron weasley and
hermione granger studied potions under
severus snape they used arsenius's book
as a reference for their writing
assignments [ __ ] wrote at length about
powerful potion-making ingredients
including moonstone snape once assigned
harry a writing task on the topic and he
would soon find out that the gem was
typically powdered and then included in
both love potions and the draft of peace
arcenius also explained the recipes and
uses for poison antidotes cures for
boils forgetfulness potions and sleeping
draughts among others
1. zigment budge
most potion makers were eccentric but
segment budge was even more peculiar
than others
likely born in the 16th century budge
was an extremely accomplished potioneer
like arsenius [ __ ] budge also created
his own textbooks on the craft of potion
making from a young age budge was drawn
to the art of elixirs and concoctions a
trait that made him not so popular with
his peers
by the time segment enrolled in hogwarts
school of witchcraft and wizardry he'd
already grown accustomed to the cruel
jeers and taunts that other children
would cast his way
even his own mother cruelly called him
fungus face a bar that the students at
hogwarts were never mean enough to say
although it's not clear whether or not
sigmund saw much of his mother the
historical record indicates that he had
a strong relationship with his
grandmother although his low self-esteem
caused him to despise her as well
despite his hatred for his family
zigment inherited his grandmother's love
of potion making that skill would serve
him well during his time at hogwarts the
year seemed to pass by quickly for budge
and when he was a third or fourth year
student he decided to leave hogwarts for
good
in those final months sigmund had proven
himself an accomplished potioneer
in class he corrected the teacher
whenever they made a mistake with their
ingredients
and at the wizarding schools potions
championship ziggman was eager to put
his skills to the test against other
magical academies like wagadu and koldov
storietz when segment asked his
headmaster the hogwarts director simply
said no
the contest was for older students and
budge was far too young to safely
participate
furious at the rejection zegman dropped
out of hogwarts and pursued potion
making on his own
unlike many other potioneers who
achieved wealth and fame zigment lived
his life in isolation the mental abuse
he suffered at the hands of his mother
was more than enough to instill a deep
dislike for people within zigment
by the time he died ziggman had
completed his book of potions
although historical records don't
indicate that he lingered as a ghost
after death his textbook was somehow
imprinted with a version of his spirit
honorable mentions there are a few other
potion masters that didn't quite make
this list but certainly deserve a spot
professor slughorn the lovable hogwarts
instructor who accidentally told
voldemort about horcruxes is quite an
accomplished potioneer he was extremely
talented at creating antidotes for
blended poisons something that only a
wizard well-versed in goldpalat's third
law could achieve
not only that he was responsible for
instructing an even greater potion maker
severus snape
when dumbledore suffered the curse of
marvolo gaunt's ring severus snape
created a potion in order to slow the
effects and extend our model's life for
one more year
even as a student snape edited his copy
of the potions textbook with updated
instructions that could create potions
quicker or make them even more effective
and with just a whiff snape could tell
the difference between polyjuice potion
and any other mixture and as you might
have guessed lord voldemort himself was
quite the accomplished potioneer his
knowledge of potions and poisons allowed
him to instruct peter pettigrew on the
exact steps of the regeneration potion
which would bring voldemort his new body
and when he was concealing one of his
horcruxes voldemort used a nasty potion
named the drink of despair to paralyze
those who consumed it with fear
there are quite a few other potion
makers who likely deserve a spot on this
list but we'll have to cover them in a
future video
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]